so in the information section for the
Slamdance website you know you talked
about back in 95 you might say you were
a group of subversive cheerful
subversive but that you you had been
denied from Sundance and you wanted to
kind of do something new I could see why
you would want to begin it but what made
you come back the second the third the
fourth and on that's a great I still
don't know yeah I mean well just to talk
about why we started slant on it's a
little bit is in ninety you know 95 was
in eighteen nineteen ninety-five feels
like eighty ninety five it was an
interesting time in independent film you
know there'd been this great crop of
filmmakers you know Sundance filmmakers
and in the early 90s and then by 95 that
a lot of the institutions of independent
film were sort of going Hollywood so
that was he or Miramax became part of
Disney it was a year a fine line became
part of Warner Brothers who's a year Fox
launched Fox Searchlight it was kind of
the studio ization of independent film
and Sundance was kind of part of you
know that whole changed that whole you
know shift and as a result they were
programming much more second time
directors directors with working with
bigger budgets and bigger stars and that
already had distribution and it was kind
of the Hollywood ization of Sundance for
one of a better term and then we came
along in 95 and we had just finished
Omaha the movie and you know we actually
premiered it at the what was then called
the IFF em or IFP market and in
September and and in previous year like
the previous year Kevin Smith had gotten
picked up there discovered by Sundance
and became Kevin Smith you know and so
we all thought alright well at least
some of us here will get will go to
Sundance and as it turned out that year
out of the 95 completed feature
narrative feature films at the IFP
market not a single one got picked up to
go to Sundance and so we're like oh man
that's kind of a drag but at the same
time we had distributors telling us good
distributors saying we love your film we
want to give you distribution if you get
into Sundance
and they said it with no shame it was
just very matter-of-fact like yeah we'll
pick you up if you get into Sundance
because and the really Sundance was kind
of all or nothing you know basically if
you got in great but if you didn't you
wouldn't get distribution you wouldn't
get you next film aid you wouldn't get
producers you wouldn't get agents you
wouldn't get into other regional
festivals you wouldn't get onto into
international festivals because they all
use the Sundance guide is the kind of
handbook so we actually heard of a
couple filmmakers the prior year in 94
who had done renegade screenings in Park
City when they didn't get it in
Sundance's so it was Trey Parker and
Matt Stone had their first film cannibal
the musical which was their film coming
out of University of Colorado this is
way before South Park and then also a
guy named James Marin Dino had a film
called the upstairs neighbor and
separately they done little screenings
in hotel rooms but had gotten a little
bit of press for it and we knew Trey and
Matt had the same lawyer as us I think
at the time so we'd heard about these
guys and we thought okay well that's an
interesting idea and especially and this
is largely Dana Altman's idea to kind of
combine it with the concept of getting
filmmakers from all over the country to
kind of help each other and combine
resources and and then we said all right
well let's stick a name on it and called
Slamdance and you know so we got
ultimately a dozen features and dozen
shorts and we showed up in Park City and
did our thing you know and and and
people loved our spirit and what we were
doing and it was a lot of fun and even
while we were there the first year we
actually put a deposit down Peter Baxter
who's now running slam and so he and I
put a deposit down on I think it was his
money I made sure it was his money yeah
on the the Yarra Hotel which which
ultimately was our venue then for the
next year and Connor with the idea that
okay there's this niche of first-time
directors working with limited budgets
who don't have distribution that was
being left behind by Sundance and so it
worked for us why not help other
filmmakers in subsequent years and I
said that's a crazy idea it'll never fly
we should just get out while the goings
good and then he's like now let's stick
with it and and we had
now we're heading into our 20th year and
over the years we've shown you know it
has been beneficial to a lot of
filmmakers who you know I mean I'm sure
their careers would have been ok but you
know we are very proud to have shown the
first films by you know Christopher
Nolan and Greg Mottola Marc Forster he's
got Planet Z or World War Z coming at
Matt Ben Zeitlin we showed her his first
short Lena Dunham house for short Lynn
Shelton director Amos Oren Peli you know
all kinds of lists kind of goes on and
on and so it's definitely it's it's
shown that there's a niche for Slamdance
even though literally by the second year
I mean as early as the second year after
we started Sundance had kind of
responded by creating different by
expanding their offerings and actually
first it was called directed necessary
the spectrum section and then now it's
called next but it's actually the same
idea you know they've added other
sections so they do show more films and
they show more fun fly first-time
directors and I think we've kind of kept
that pressure on them to to stay more
relevant but the reality is they're
still so many films and there's still
enough good ones that you know there's
enough for for everyone so it's not very
it's not dissimilar also from Can Has
Directors Fortnight which started in
1968 or 69 by a group of disgruntled
directors and it's still going on
you know 42 years later or something so
so you know it's it's a you know we
didn't invent the wheel you know it's a
tradition in the film festival world and
it goes back to other art institutions
for hundreds of years back to what I'm
wondering is when something's new and
fresh people kind of champion it a
little bit and then time sets in and for
whatever reasons sometimes roadblocks
appear or whatever it is whether it's
people get tired of it or whatever did
you experience that with the festival
maybe in your fifth year or whatever and
how did you move through that because
sometimes there's these growing pains
that don't happen right away right and
then stuff gets doors get shut well with
every festival that I've know closely
usually about the third year
you know that's when people turn on each
other and there's these internecine
battles and arguments that go on behind
the scenes and yes my man's went through
that a few times you know over the years
but that keeps it interesting oh sure
but then there are the external
roadblocks I mean Sundance tried to kick
us out of town and they they had the
sheriff literally the this the police
chief in town tried to kick us out
multiple times over the years they would
try to buy us out of each of these
venues and we got very I mean partially
by design and by luck we found a great
home finally after a couple of years at
the treasure mountain in which is run by
a great couple Andy and Thea who they
didn't particularly like Sundance so
they were like the one kind of
mom-and-pop hotel left in town that the
rest were kind of more corporate ties
and so they were like hey we'd like
these Slamdance guys this is more our
style and so they've been a great home
for us over the years and now Andy's
actually on the City Council so you know
and and now we're friends with the new
mayor and yeah so you know I mean it's
it's not for nothing I started in
politics you know we knew early on
coming to make friends with the local
because a lot of the locals don't
particularly like Sundance you know so
for all kinds of reasons so we're like
okay it's much easier for local Park
City people to buy tickets to Slamdance
and we make it a lot simpler and easier
for them and you know a lot of them
really like us but part of it is also we
we stuck very early to a very strict
sort of mantra of how we would run
things so the main competition it's just
first time directors you know limited
budgets with with no us distribution in
place so we're not so we avoided a lot
of the traps that happened to Sundance
and also to a lot of other little
upstart festivals that sort of came and
went over the years in Park City and
they're having a lot of them but you
know we've never been beholding to
Harvey Weinstein or any or anyone else
just by virtue of how we set set it up
in the first place and also the way we
do our programming every film was
watched by at least two people all the
programmers are filmmakers themselves
there's no one senior programmer
at all and there never has been and you
know there's no early invitation so you
know we can't just go to Toronto and say
oh I like that film that's program that
and then by the time you get to the main
programming there's only two slots left
for anyone with us it's you know all the
decisions are made at the the final time
so it's very unique in the festival
world how we do our programming and all
the programmers are alumni filmmakers
themselves so they've all been through
this so you know so by kind of setting
up these kind of institutional you know
methods of how we do things that's given
us our credibility over the long term I
think
you